t
enfin comblés, ou presque.
Après plusieurs tentatives de
fécondation in vitro échouées,
entendre battre le coeur
de leur enfant à naître.
- Au lieu de ça, on m'a dit que
mon bébé allait mourir.
Qu'il n'y avait rien à faire.
- C'était en avril de l'an
passé. Le début d'un long
cauchemar.
- Ça a été un choc pour moi.
J'en ai perdu le souffle.avavava
dit que ce n'était pas de la loi
introduite par le gouvernement
actuel, il aurait interrompu
ma grossesse sur le champ,
mais que j'allais devoir
attendre que le coeur du bébé
s'arrête complètement.
- Mais pour ces hohohohohohors
de question d'avorter cette
grossesse, pourtant condamnée.
- Tous les matins, j'avais
une échographie et des testssani
le bébé était encore en vie.
Je ne pouvais qu'attendre,
allongée dans mon lit ou
attaquer. C'étai,,,,,,
parce que je savais que je
perdais du liquide amniotique.
Je savais que mon bébé était
en souffrance, qu'il étouffait
et je ne pouvais pas l'aider.
- Lui, elle et son mari l'ont
t.t.t.t.t.t.t. Si Camila a été
forcée de le porter jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus aucun signe
de vie, c'est qu'il y a un an,
ononononononon de la Cour
constitutionnelle de la Pologne
a pris effet. Cette dernière a
jugé anticonstitutionnel le fain
grave et irréversible du foetus
ou de maladie incurable
qui menace la vie du foetus. j n
des rares motifs légaux
pour recourir à l'avortement
en Pologne. Il représentaitaiais
quelque 1000 avortements légaux
pratiqués chaque année
dans le pays, selon Amnistieint.
La très pieuse et conservatrice
Pologne est de
la rue en masse pour dénoncer
cette décision de la Cour.
Si Camila a vécu un drame
psychologique inqualifiable,
elle soutient que le refus
de ses médecins d'avorter
a mis sa propre vie en danger.
- J'avais peur, parce qu
je ne savais pas ce qui allait
se passer, si mon état allait
s'aggraver, développer une
infection. J'avais p
une hémorragie en pleine nuit et
que je ne pourrais pas demander
de l'aide.
- C'est ce qui est arrivé àIsabe
dernier. Enceinte de cinq mois,
la jeune mère de famille est
morte alors qu'elle ne pouvait
avorter. Les circonstances
de son décès ont été rendues
publiques par sa famille en
novembre. Isabella avait échangé
avec sa mère par messages texte
peu avant sa mort, lui disant
toute sa peur.
"Ma fièvre monte, écrivait-ele.
Je suis en danger."
Lorsquetetetetetetetetetetenté
une césarienne, il était déjà
trop tard. Isabella est décédée
d'un choc septique.
Une
s'est défendu l'hôpital.
Une explication qui n'a pas
convaincu une grande partie
des Polonais, qui ont renouvelé
les manifestations en masse
pour demander le droit
à l'avortement.
Depuis l'arrêté de la cour il y
a un an, l'avortement en Pologne
est légal seulement en cas de
viol et de danger pour la santé
de la mère. ceux qui
pratiquerait des interruptions
de grossesse en cas de
malformation du foetus risquent
jusqu'à trois ans de prison.
Et c'est là tout le problème.
disent les féministes,
AGATHA CZAFNACKA
- Ce sont les médecins qui ont
peur d'interrompre la grossesse
qui est perdue, qui est foutue.
Mais quand même, il faut
maintenir la vie du foetus,
même au coût de la vie de femme.
Et c'est ça qui a changé.
C'est ça qui est vraiment
profondément bouleversant.
- Les réseaux parallèles
d'entraide entre femmes
étaient déjà en plein essor.
Aujourd'hui, ils se disent
débordés. Dans les bureauxlelels
l'équipe de rêve de
l'avortement, le téléphone
sonne sans arrêt.
A l'autre bout du fil,
des femmes qui souhaitent
interrompre leur grossesse,
elles sont alors dirigées
vers les ressources qui
s'offrent à elle à l'étranger.
Pour celles qui n'en auraient
pas les moyens, ces
organisations offrent aussi
le financement du voyage,
en Allemagne et aux Pays-Bas
le plus souvent, et le coût de
l'intervention. Depuis octobre
2020, 34 000femmes polonaises
ont ainsi pu avorter.
Dans 80 % des cas, elles ont
eu recours à la pilule abortive
et un peu plus de 1000 d'entre
elles ont dû faire le voyage
à l'étranger.
- Chacune d'entre nous a
comprend que ça peut être moi,
que si c'est moi, j'aurais pas
de l'assistance, j'aurais pas
de l'aide. Je peux mourir,
justement, mourir pour la
grossesse. Donc ça, c'est assez
même, parce que nous sommes
vraiment terrorisées, nous,s s .
- C'est bien de la terreur que
Camila a ressenti, une terreur
imposée par l'État, croit-elle,
et elle souhaite que les femmes
polonaises en soient libérés.
Longtemps, elle a hésité
à raconter son histoire,
de peur d'être stigmatisée.
- J'essaie de rester brave
et de garder la tête haute
et de raconter. Si ce n'était
de l'appui de ma famille, je ne
pourrais pas parler de ce que
j'ai vécu. Ils m'ont encouragée
à le faire pour que les gens
comprennent ce qui se passe.
- Camila ignore si elle pourra
un jour enterrer sa souffrance,
mais elle ne veut certainement
pl